just talk us through the kind of thing
you've been witnessing in the last few
days
well it's a it's a huge Calamity and the
very first day the day that it happened
we've got down there sort of sometime in
the afternoon and the first thing that
struck us was first how much water there
was there and secondly how few people
were actually helping and how most of
the people who were helping were
ukrainians by that stage there had
already been declared an emergency
president zielinski had been up since
the beginning of the morning telling
everyone that it were holding emergency
meetings with his National Security
Council alerting the world that there'd
been this huge Calamity the mayor of the
area had been telling people to get out
save yourselves move quickly because the
critical point was going to hit within a
few hours and that's exactly what
happened over the next three four days
we saw the waters creep up and up and up
so streets that we were able to Wade
through at the beginning you couldn't
get down without a boat by the following
morning and then the third morning it
was it was up covering the top of street
signs and the tip of ruse
even three four days on there was still
hardly any sign certainly that we saw
any evidence at all of international Aid
organizations taking part in What was
clearly a huge humanitarian and
ecological disaster it was mainly
volunteers a lot of Ukrainian volunteers
Ukrainian residents who were just
finding their own boats getting dinghies
and and pushing them out to try and save
animals and humans many of whom had
stayed after that first night thinking
because the waters were coming in at a
regular but slowish Pace they'd stayed
overnight and then the following morning
found themselves you know surrounded by
water and unable to get out with no
electricity and things were obviously
going to get worse and worse so the
president zelenski by the third day was
really denouncing what he called the
shameful indifference by a certain
Global World players who really
criticize the aid organizations of
course remember a lot of the aid
organizations are already based in
Ukraine because of the ongoing
humanitarian catastrophe calls caused by
the war
um so there was there was no sudden
having to rush to this country to help
out they were already based here but
very very few seem to be on the ground
actually helping out and then by
Thursday it got even worse because by
this stage there were quite a large
collection of Ukrainian volunteers
citizens trying to help out and and
really motor the the relief operation
when the there was a lot of shelling and
attacks right on the evacuation points
more than one evacuation points which we
witnessed ourselves and this morning
we've heard that the UN has asked for
and been refused permission to get to
the the Left Bank which is under Russian
occupation the other side of the danipro
river so there is an ongoing human
catastrophe and ecocide is how president
zielinski described that this
environmental catastrophe because it's
not just the short-term impact of what's
happening right in front of us with
elderly frail vulnerable people and
children some of whom are fleeing
themselves from the Russian occupied
side and making it over and talking
about how Russian troops are looting
their houses on the Left Bank how they
themselves appear to have been taken
Surprise by the damn birth and how
they're trying to steal their boats to
escape and and how they feel like the
the they're being attacked as they're
leaving not only is that happening but
there's an ongoing long-term impact of
600 square kilometers of just the
hairson region the case on oblast which
is underwater and this water is filthy
it's full of sewage oil toxic
chemicals all sorts of things as well as
floating landmines which have been
dislodged by this torrent of water which
is rushing down and we've seen 160
kilometers away from here some City in
Odessa sofas and broken washing machines
and even a dog floating on top of a door
Landing up 160 kilometer kilometers
Downstream of the river so a huge
catastrophe here that's unfolding on top
of the war with evacuations being
conducted Under Fire